uh you're on record saying that you did
not like Chris Paul how has that has how
is your perspective on that changed uh
since you've been able to work with him
play with him if at all uh I've had some
conversations with him
um with Chris over the last
a couple months that I haven't
necessarily had
um not only with Chris but just in my
career uh
Chris
and and I've said this before too on the
record he's one of the smartest guys in
this league uh when when you talk
basketball IQ you know I've said on
record Chris Paul
LeBron James
Rajon Rondo and Rondo like I've said
that on record a million times and so
um number one that we've had
conversations basketball conversations
that I've just been excited to have
because it's sitting and speaking with
the guy with the IQ level of Chris Paul
for me like I'm I I can get basketball
geeky at times I love the game of
basketball I think one of my best
attributes as a basketball player is my
IQ and so
and speaking to a high IQ guy like Chris
for me that's everything like that's
gold and we've been able to share in
those conversations uh we've been able
to share in a bunch of conversations
we've been collaborative on things
things that you do with teammates we've
we've been doing and in doing that
you start to get to know people outside
of just what you're doing as far as
basketball goals and you know I'm
starting to get you know I've started to
get to know Chris better
um I didn't know Chris at all outside of
competing with him if you've ever
watched Chris compete he's kind of an
you may say the same thing about
me
um and that's okay but
he's also one of the most competitive
guys that you know I've played in
against over my 11 years in this league
I'm also an extremely competitive guy
and I'm not backing down from anyone
he's not backing down from anyone that
will bring some clashes and it has
brought plenty of them when you look at
uh the last seven eight years
um in the NBA Chris Paul is right at the
center of all of it
and guess what so are we and we weren't
on teams
if there wasn't any hate then I you know
we everybody get to talking like oh man
those guys are too friendly or why are
they working out together this that in
today's NBA
but then when you have competitors
hating each other
then that's like oh man they hate each
other like how is that even possible
well you gotta pick a side like you
either wants to be friends and all work
out together and everybody accept it or
you want us to hate each other
and in this case we competed like we're
trying to get championships and Chris is
trying to get championships and guess
what when you're competing for that
at the level that we've competed for
that
that sometimes bring hate
because we're going after the same thing
and that definitely had brought that
between us but look at the runs we run
Houston was right at the center of that
the Clippers were right at the center of
that and so Phoenix was right at the
center of that so you look at
in the league 11 years we've been
competing on a championship level for
eight he's at the center of six of them
of course there's going to be some
animosity and there was a lot of it now
in saying that
um we're adults we're men and we have an
opportunity to go do something special
together would never let that go by the
wayside and you know and just getting to
know Chris and seeing how he operates
seeing how he moves how he carries
himself how he walking how he walks in
the gym every day like it makes sense of
why
he is who he is why he's had the success
that he's had and and I'm growing to
know that I'm
learning from that I don't think you're
ever too good or done too much to learn
from someone
Chris Paul has been in this league what
18 years
definitely somebody I can learn from I'm
excited about it uh we're we're growing
and more more fastest than one and it's
uh it's been an incredible
start to it and I know like I said for
for both of us
um the goal is to win and I know he want
to win
as we all know and my goal is to do all
that I can to make sure help him win and
anything that happened before that
happened and
it definitely doesn't change our past
like us becoming teammates don't change
the things that's happened in the past
we have battled
and battle for sure but I think the part
that I'm most excited about is like you
now get to know the person and I know
for myself and where I can probably
relate to Chris most people probably
hate me that don't know me
I think if you get to know me you don't
necessarily hate me but if you don't
know me you probably hate me
and Chris definitely got some of that
himself if you don't know him you
probably hate him you get to know him
and you realize there's a competitor and
a person but
you know it's not always easy to see
that when when you're in the heat of the
battle you know when you step outside
the heat of the battle you can separate
those two things and I am thankful to
have the opportunity to separate the two
things